[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى تردون هذه الصور من الخرطوم
في ظل توتر وخلاف محتدما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ودعوات من
قوى مدنيه لتغليب صوت العقل بعد تحركات
للدعم السريع دون موافقه القوات المسلحه
هذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من باريس مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات بشان قانون التقاعد
الذي مررته الحكومه الفرنسيه دون تصويت
البرلمان
وهذه الصور مباشره من نيويورك حيث عاد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دانل ترامب مجددا
ليتم الاستماع اليه في اطار محاكمه مدنيه
تتعلق بتهم احتيال ضمن مجموعه منظمه وذلك
بعد اسبوع من توجيه اتهامات جنائيه اليه
في قضيه منفصله
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
بعد تحذيرات ومخاوف من ضرر على الامن
القومي الامريكي مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
يعتقل المشتبه به في تسريب وثائق سريه
امريكيه تقارير صحفيه تقول انه اختصاصي
بتقنيه المعلومات في استخبارات الحرس
الوطني
البنتاجون يقول ان تسريب معلومات سريه كان
عملا اجراميا متعمدا ويقر بتاثير التسريب
على علاقات واشنطن مع الحلفاء
محذرا من تحركات تنذر بمواجهه وتشكل
تجاوزا واضحا للقانون وجب علينا ان ندق
ناقوس الخطر الجيش السوداني يتهم الدعم
السريع بحشد القوات داخل العاصمه وبعض
المدن الدعم السريع يقول انه يعمل في اطار
القانون وبالتنسيق مع الجيش وبقيه القوات
النظاميه وبيان امريكي اوروبي يدعو اطراف
الازمه الى خفض التصعيد
[تصفيق]
كقرار حاسما للمجلس الدستوري بشان تعديل
قانون التقاعد مئات الالاف يتظاهرون في
باريس ومدن فرنسيه وسط صدمات بين شرطه
ومحتجي
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
صندوق النقد يتوقع نموا اكثر بطئا في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في العام
الجاري
[موسيقى]
اذا اعتقل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
المشتبه فيه بتسريب وثائق البنتاجون بعد
مداهمه منزله رافضا اعطاء مزيد من
المعلومات وقال وزير العدل الامريكي ان
الامر جرى دون اي تعقيدات وقال مسؤولون
امريكيون ان المسؤول عن التسريب هو جاك
تشيره احد افراد الحرس الوطني الجوي في
ماسجوست واظهرت صور لحظه مداهمه مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي منزل والدتي تشيرا
واعتقاله ونقلت سي ان ان عن مكتب المدعي
العامه سيمثل غدا الجمعه امام المحكمه في
بوسطن
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون ان
الوثائق التي صربت حساسه وانما حدث جريمه
متعمده ورفض المتحدث باسم البنتاجون
مناقشه التفاصيل الوثائق المسربه بسبب
حساسيتها وتاثيرها على الامن القومي
والحلفاء والشركاء حسب تعبيره واوضح ان
لدى البنتاجون قواعد صارمه للحفاظ على
الوثائق السريه وان العمل متواصل مع
الوكالات الفيدراليه لمعرفه حجم الضرر
الذي احدثه التسريب
ومع تكشف المعلومات مع الاكثر فاكثر عن
تفاصيل تسريب الوثائق السريه الامريكيه
يتاكد من جديد ان كبرى عمليه التسريب
للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه في الولايات
المتحده يقف خلفها دوما اشخاص من داخل
المؤسسات العسكريه وليس عبر الاختراقات او
القرصنه الالكترونيه
وفق وسائل اعلام امريكيه فان شابا عشرينيا
مولعا بالاسلحه الناريه يدعى هو الذي يقف
خلف اكبر تسريب لوثائق استخباراتيه سريه
في الولايات المتحده منذ عشر سنوات ونجح
في الوصول اليها خلال عمله عضوا في
مخابرات الحرس الوطني الجوي في ولايه ماسه
اذ كان يعمل تقنيا في قسم تكنولوجيا
المعلومات
تكسيرا بدا العام الماضي بنشر المعلومات
السريه في مجموعه دردشه على منصه المراسله
الفوريه ديسكورد التي تستقطب الملعنه
بالعاب الفيديو
وبحسب مقابلات اجرتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست
مع عضويني في مجموعه الدردشه فان تكسيرا
الذي اطلق على نفسه اسم اوجي وكان يدير
المجموعه قال عن المعلومات لحظه نشرها
بانها نصوص من وثائق السريه احضرها الى
المنزل من مقر عمله داخل القاعده العسكريه
مضيفا بانه نسخ كثيرا من تلك الوثائق
باليد لانه يحضر على من يدخل القاعده
العسكريه حمل الهواتف او الاجهزه
الالكترونيه على مدى اشرن كانت يعطي
زملائه في مجموعه الدردشه قدرا صغيرا من
الاسرار لكن وعندما تبين له ان تحويل مئات
الملفات السريه يدويا كان مرهقا للغايه
بدا بنشر مئات الصور للوثائق نفسها التي
تسربت لاحقا على عده مواقع ومنصات مثل
تويتر وتليجرام
اللافت في المعلومات التي كشف عنها
الاعلام الامريكي انه يؤكد من جديد ان
القاسم المشترك الاهم في عمليات التسريب
الاستخباراتيه الكبرى في الولايات المتحده
هو العامل البشري وليس تطور ادوات
وبرمجيات التجسس والاختراق والقرصنه
الالكترونيه ولعل هذا ما يفسر ايضا قيام
البنتاجون بتقليص قوائم المسؤولين الذين
يتلقون الملخصات الاستخباراتيه اليوميه
بعد تفجر ازمه التسريب في عام 2010 بدا
موقع ويكيليكس الذي اسسه جوليان اسانج نشر
عدد هائل من الوثائق العسكريه السريه
المسربه توضح تفاصيل ممارسات القوات
الامريكيه وقوات التحالف خلال الحرب
الامريكيه على العراق في المده ما بين
عامي
2009 وتبين لاحقا ان الجزء الاكبر من هذه
الوثائق المسربه كان وراءه جندي امريكي
يعمل محللا للمعلومات البالغه السريه في
عام 2013 سرب المتعاقد السابق مع وكاله
الامن القومي الامريكي ادواردسن مئات
الالاف من الوثائق السريه كشفت قيام
الحكومه الامريكيه بالتجسس على مواطنين
امريكيين ومسؤولين اجانب بما في ذلك قاده
دول حليفه للولايات المتحده
تورطت بها وكاله الامن القومي
والاستخبارات الامريكيه
ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد
كيف يتطور الموقف بعد اعتقاله والقاء
القبض على تشير وماذا عن ابرز ردود الفعل
على كل ما تكشف في هذه القضيه
هذا الاعتقال او هذا الكشف عن اسم تشيره
ومن ثم اعتقاله لا يزال التفاعل فيه
مقتصرا على وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه التي
تناقلت كما ذكرت انه سيمثل امام المحكمه
غدا الجمعه في بوسطن ومن ثم ستوجه اليه
حديث وزير العدل الامريكي الذي اعلن عن
هذا الاعتقال والحديث واسع على انه ستوجه
له التوام بناء على ما يعرف هنا في
الولايات المتحده بالاسكيناجات او قانون
التخريب هو القانون الذي يجرم او يحدد مدى
وحدود واطر التعريف الجريمي الجرمي لعمليه
تسريب وثائق سريه بغيه الاضرار بالولايات
المتحده او خدمه لاجنده اجنبيه بالنسبه
للمحققين ال سي ستكون الغايه الاولى هنا
من هذا من هذا الاعتقال هو الكشف عن دوافع
دوافع هذا الشاب في الكشف والتسريب هذه
الوثائق السريه ومن ثم يبقى هو متهما حتى
ان تثبت ادانته على امام المحاكم لكن حتى
اللحظه ما لدينا من معلومات انه هو كان
مدير هذه غرفه الدردشه هذه وهو من حسب حسب
التهم قام بتسريب هذه المعلومات بدايه كما
ذكرت تقرير
بخط يده ومن ثم بنقل هذه الوثائق صورا
واذا استمعنا الى صديقه والعضو فيها غرفه
الدردشه هذه انما تحدث الى الواشنطنبوز
فان ربما غايته ربما الاستشفاف بان غايته
كانت التباهي امام الاعضاء البقيه في هذه
الغرفه والحديث عن تجاوزات لدى الحكومه
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بالمسائل الحقوقيه
ومسائل حقوق الانسان وتجاوزات ضد حلفاء
امريكيين وكان صديقوه قد قال بانه ليس
مواليا لروسيا وليس مدفوعا من قبلها كما
كما تردد في وسائل الاعلام في البدايه
عندما تمت كشف عن هذه الوثائق بالنسبه
لتصريحات المسؤول الامريكيين لو اتخذنا
المتحدث تصريح الرئيس الامريكي ايضا صباح
اليوم الاخطر بالنسبه لهؤلاء ليس محتوى
هذه الوثائق وانما عمليه التسريب بحد
ذاتها وكان الرئيس الامريكي صريحا عندما
قال بانما يقلقني هو عمليه التسريب وليس
محتوى ما سرب في هذه الوثائق السريه لان
الولايات المتحده ربما تكون قادره على
احتواء اضرار واثارها هذا هذه هذا المحتوى
على علاقتها مع حلفائها او حتى على مساله
امنها القومي لكن اذا تم استسهال عمليات
التسريب في المستقبل فسيكون هذا الامن
القومي الامريكي وعمليات التجسس الامريكيه
في الخارج في خطر كبير شكرا لك احمد هزيم
مراسلنا من واشنطن
من نيويورك ينضموا الينا العقيد مايلز
الضابط السابق في الجيش الامريكي والباحث
في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه مرحبا بك
العقيد مايلز هل من الطبيعي ان يكون
لشاب عشريني عضو في
الجهاز الذي يعمل به ان تكون له امكانيه
الوصول الى هذه المعلومات الحساسه والسريه
مرحبا مساء الخير
ومرحبا مساء الخير ورمضان كريم
لدينا محللون من الشباب الصغار الذين
يقومون بتجهيزه هذه المعلومات التي هي في
غايه السريه لكي تستخدم من قبل اعضاء
اخرين وعناصر في الجيش كل عضو لديه سبيل
وتصريح للوصول الى هذه المعلومات السريه
قام
بالمرور
بعمليه التحقق من السوابق
وخلفيته وذلك لكي يتم البث في مصداقيته
بالتعامل مع هذه المعلومات السريه للغايه
اذا اين التقصير فيما حصل باعتقادك
هذا الشخص الشاب الذي يعمل في القوات
الجويه تشير اتخذ هذا القرار
بانتهاك القواعد ونشر معلومات سريه في
مجموعته الخاصه بالدردشه مع اصدقائه الذين
يقومون بممارسه الالعاب لذلك وزاره العدل
تقوم بالتحقيق في السبب الذي جعله يتخذ
هذا القرار ومن النادر جدا في هذه الحاله
ان تكون معلومات سريه كهذه يتم تبادلها
بطريقه غير قانونيه اذا فبالتالي هذه
مشكله تخص هذا الشاب الصغير في العمر ولكن
بشكل عام المعلومات السريه للحكومه
الامريكيه يتم تخزينها والتعامل معها
بطريقه امنه
ربما ايضا سيد مالا يقول خطوره هو انه قام
بنشر هذه المعلومات السريه على مدى شهر
عبر تطبيق ديسكورد ولم يتم لم
ينتبه لذلك مجتمع المخابرات الامريكي الا
بعد ان خرجت من هذا التطبيق ايضا ماذا
يقول لنا هذا الامر
تجربتي في الجيش والبيت الابيض
في قطاع الاستخبارات يعملون دائما
[موسيقى]
ان خاصه تخص المعلومات السريه الخاصه وهم
يتبادلون المعلومات
عن طريق الانترنت بطريقه امنه هذا الشخص
الذي يعمل في القوات الجويه طبعا هذه
المعلومات ونشرها لذلك سيكون من المهم
للحكومه الامريكيه ان يكون هناك اناس
وعناصر داخل هذه المجموعات مثل ديسكورد
وغيرها الذين يقومون برصد تبادل هذه
المعلومات السريه ولكن لا يمكننا ان نتحقق
وان نتاكد من كل شيء طوال الوقت شكرا لك
العقيد والضابط السابق في الجيش الامريكي
والباحث في مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه ضيفا
من نيويورك
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الان الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذه العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه مرحبا بك دكتور خليل ما الذي
استوقفك في هذه القضيه وما تكشف عن خلفيات
هذا التسريب
انا اعتقد عده نقاط او نقطه متعلقه بحجم
المعلومات التي تم تسريبه من ناحيه الحجم
من ناحيه المستوى الرفيع السريه هنتكلم عن
المعلومات السريه للغايه لا يفترض ان يصل
اليها شخص عادي هنتكلم هنا في هذه الحاله
شاب عشرين واحد وعشرين سنه جاك تشيره انشا
هذه المجموعه مجموعه الدردشه على موقع
ديسكورد قبل حاجه من الان وهي مجموعه خاصه
للدردشه ثم نشر معلومات سريه للغايه
السؤال المهم جدا اولا كيف حصل عليها على
يبدو انه متعاقد يعني حتى اللحظه اذا كان
هو يعني شخص عضو في يعمل بشكل رتبه عسكريه
ام شخص مدني يعمل في اطار مخابرات الحرس
الجوي حرس الوطني الجوي فيه ولا وبالتالي
هناك سماء مهم حول كيف حصل هذه المعلومات
المتعلق هل يعمل لوحده ام مرتبط بجمعه
اخرى او باطراف اخرى او بشخصيات اخرى سواء
داخل امريكا او خارجها لان الموضوع اصبح
له ابعاد دوليه وخارجيه وبالتالي كبير جدا
حول هل يتصرف من ذاته ام هناك اف راد
اخرون يمدن هذه المعلومات ده سؤال مهم جدا
الامر الثالث متعلق
هل سيتم محاكمه امام محكمه عسكريه محكمه
فيدراليه هذا يعتبر امر مهم جدا
يتحدثوا عن محاكمه عمان الحكمه الفدراليه
العليا في قضيه مدنيه هل سيتم محاكمته
بشكل قاسي ام بشكل اقل من اعتباري صغير في
السن فهناك اسئله كثيره جدا المعلقه حتى
هذه اللحظه يجب ان ينتظر حتى نجيب عليها
هل من المبكر السؤال دكتور خليل عن
المقارنه بين عمليه التسريب هذا الذي حدثت
والتي يعتبرها البنتاجون عمل جورمي متعمد
وتسريبات اخرى جرت في السابق لنفس النوع
من الوثائق السريه
لقد يكون الفرق فقط في حجم الوثائق لو
بنتكلم مثلا لو قارن على اقرب مثال لذلك
هو حاله 2013 بهذه الحاله بنتكلم عن فرقه
كبير جدا في الحجم وكميه الوثائق
نشر الاف الوثائق او مئات الالاف من
الوثائق التي كانت لديك الوقت وليت ايضا
انت تتدار كبير جدا في علاقات مع الدول
الخارجيه هذه الحاله حتى هذه اللحظه
بنتكلم على عده مئات تم نشر على الاقل 100
وثقه منها قليل منها جدا في تغييرات او في
تزييف او في تزوير خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا لكن بشكل عام معظم
الوثائقي وثائق اصليه على الاقل حسب ما
جاء في وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
الامر الثاني متعلق بتوقيت هذه الوثائق
بنتكلم الان على الوثائق جت على مدار مثلا
نتكلم مغطيه اخر سبع اسابيع فقط من الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ممارسه الداخليه
وبالتالي حديثه جدا فرق المقارنه مثلا
بوفاق ستودين كانت قبل عشر سنوات او قبل
سنوات قبل ذلك يعني على الاقل منذ الحرب
الامريكيه على العراق 2023 حتى تم نشرها
في 2013 وبالتالي الفرق في التوقيت مهم
جدا باينه كده الامرين وهنا ربما يجري
التوقف عندما قاله الرئيس الامريكي اليوم
من ان هذه هذا التسريب خطير ولكن ربما لن
تكون له تداعيات جديه وكارثيه على ما يحدث
على الارض كيف وجدت هذا الكلام
اتفق لحد بعيد نتكلم اولا على ليست المره
الاولى كانت هناك يعني حوادث مشابهه اكثر
يعني تاثيرا من ذلك ولا نعلم جميعا مثل ما
حدث اليوم 13 عندما حدثت ازمه علاقات
الامريكيه الالمانيه بعدما تم الكشف عن
انه امريكا تقوم بالتنصت على
السابقه ايضا في العلاقه مع البرازيل ومع
كندا الامر مختلف هذه المره حتى لحظه هناك
محاوله لملمه طبعا هناك احراج دولي
لامريكا خاصه فيما يتعلق بامكاني الثقه
بها كوثيق كطرف به ثقه لانه تسريب معلومات
مثلا خاصه بالعلاقات ما بين الامارات وبين
روسيا ما بين داخل اسرائيل العلاقات ما
بين مصر وروسيا العلاقات بين كوريا
واوكرانيا هذه المسائل تمثل احراج كبير
لامريكا لكن بشكل عام انا في رايي الشخصي
سيتم الامور خاصه نتكلم عن العلاقات
استراتيجيه قويه بين هذه البلدان بين
امريكا الصعب جدا توقع حدوث تداعيات كبيره
على المدى المتوسط الطويل على الاقل اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث طالبت القوى السياسيه
اطراف المكونه العسكري بخفض التصعيد
والدخول في حوار لحل الازمه وقد شهدت
العاصمه الخرطوم تحركات لنزع فتيل التوتر
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وقد نشر الجيش السوداني قواته في الخرطوم
ومحيطي مطار مدينه مروي بالولايه الشماليه
ردا على انتشار مماثل لقوات الدعم السريع
هذا هو اجرى قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حميتي مباحثات هاتفيه مع المبعوثين
الامريكي مع المبعوثين الامريكي
والبريطاني والنرويجي بشان التطورات وابدح
بيتي حرصه على تعزيز الاستقرار ودعم مسيره
التحول الديمقراطي بالبلاد
ارتال عسكريه تابعه للقوات الدعم السريع
في شوارع الخرطوم واخرى في مدينه مروي
بالولايه الشماليه اعاده انتشار قابلها
الجيش بتحركات مماثله فنشرت قواتي في
مناطق عده بالعاصمه الخرطوم وارسل تعزيزات
الى محيط مطار مدينه مرو وقال انه يجهل
خلفيات هذا الانتشار الذي جرى دون التنسيق
معه وجب علينا ان ندق ناقوس الخطر
بان بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن
قوات الدعم السريع قالت من جانبها ان
تحركاتها جاءت وفقا للقانون وحذرت من
مواصفاتها بشائعات التي تزرع الفتنه وتقوض
استقرار الوطن وامنه الازمه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع دفعت القوى السياسيه
الى عقد اجتماع طاري لبحث الازمه واجرى
الاتفاق على ارسال وفد الى كلا الطرفين
لوقف التصعيد الاعلامي والعسكري وتوصلوا
الى
رؤيه مشتركه
بان الامر يتطلب
جمع الصفوه الوطني
مدنيين وعسكريين
وينظر الى هذه التوترات على انها امتداد
للخلافات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
بشان كيفيه الادماج والتباعد مواقفهما من
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي اجل تنفيذه اكثر من
مره نتيجه هذه الخلافات وهذا الاعتقال
المستمر والطويل بلغت هذه الازمه اشدها
ربما هذا التصعيد يكون لقسم مواقف تفاعليه
الان ولكن يمكن ان ينفلت لانه من الصعوبه
من مكان ان تحقق مواقف او كسوف تفاضيه عن
طريق المناورات العسكريه
خلافات سياسيه اذا بين قوات الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع تحولت الى خلافات
عسكريه وترجمت بنشر القوات للدعم السريع
في مروي قبل ان تشاهد اليات تابعه لتلك
القوات في العاصمه الخرطوم في وقت تسعى
فيه القوى السياسيه للتهدئه وتجنب حدوث
تصعيد لن تحمد عقبه الطاهر المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم
اعرب المبعوثون والممثلون الخاصون من
فرنسا والمانيا والنرويج وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
اعربوا عن قلق بالغ ازاءه تصاعد التوترات
في السودان وخطر التصعيد بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين قائد القوات البحريه السوداني
السابق ومعنا ايضا حافظ كبير الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك سيد
حافظ كبير ماذا وراء خطوات قوات الدعم
السريع بالانتشار في مروي وايضا في
العاصمه الخرطوم من دون التنسيق مع قوات
الجيش
تحيه لكم ولمشاهديكم الكرام وكذلك لضيفك
الكريم هذه الخطوه تاتي في اطار الصراع
حول الاتفاق الاطار او حول العمليه
السياسيه برمتها هناك تباين واضح بين
قياده الجيش وبين قياده الدعم السريع حول
ضروره الالتزام بما تم التوقيع عليه في
الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي وضروره التسليم
السلطه للمدنيين كما تابعنا ان القياده
الجيش دائما
تصدر تصريحات متضاربه بشان التزامها
بالعمليه السياسيه وكذلك التزامها بقضيه
التحول المدني الديمقراطي وهناك يعني
اصطدمت المواقف بعد الورشه ورشه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري عندما انسحب ممثل او
انسحب ممثله الجيش من جلسه التوصيات
الاخيره وهذا يعني
بصوره او باخرى انسحاب من الالتزام الذي
قطعته الاطراف على عمليه اصلاح اصلاح
الجيش وكذلك اصلاح المنظومه كلها وبالتالي
تبقى يعني واستبقت وسيله وهي ان يفرض
الجيش عبر القوه المسلحه رؤيته باعتبار
انه لا يتفق مع الورشه المطروح فيها
عمليات واجراءات الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وكذلك لا يتفق مع العمليه السياسيه التي
وقع هو على اتفاق اطار لها وكذلك وقع على
مبادئ اسس للاصلاح الامني والعسكري الجيش
او قياده الجيش اقصد بشكل دقيق يعني تعرف
ان قوتها في فرض السيطره على كل الاسلحه
وبالتالي وجود سلاح خارجها لا يتفق معها
سياسيا امر مغلق بالنسبه لها واكثر يعني
الاماكن التي تستطيع منها فرض سيطرتها هي
الاسلحه الكبيره والمهمه وبالتالي هي تريد
يعني ان تفرض سيطرتها على
السياسيه واقصد لانه الجيش ظل يعمل
بالتنسيق مع الدعم السريع طوال الفتره
السابقه وكذلك مع قوات اخرى ولم يمثل ذلك
اي اشكال خلال الفتره السابقه لولا
العمليه السياسيه التي يتضح الجرير ان
قياده الجيش لا تثق بها ولا تريد المضي
فيها الى نهايتها
المتفقات من جانب قوات الدعم السريع هي من
اجل فرد دخول الاتفاق الاطاري حيز التنفيذ
ما رايك بهذا الكلام
الكريم والساده المشاهدين
لا اقول ذلك ابدا اقول ان هنالك مخطط رسم
بدقه وعنايه كبيره جدا يهدف الى ايجاد
قوات موازيه للقوات المسلحه واقصد بذلك
قوات الدعم السريع هنالك جزء من المكونات
السياسيه المواقعه في الاتفاق الايطالي
سعت لا يكون الدعم السريع خارج سيطره
المسلحه خلال الفتره الانتقاليه لكي يكون
جيشا موازيا مع ان القانون الذي انشئ به
انشئت كقوات مسانده للقوات المسلحه وليست
موازيه الان هم يريدونها تكون قوات مغازيه
ويريدون ان تكون لهم ظهير في مواجهه
القوات المسلحه اذا ما مضوا في اجنداتهم
التي لا تخدم مصلحه الشعب السوداني ويريد
ان يمددوا بها الفكره الانتقاليه الى
مديات طويله بحجه ان هنالك قوات خارج
السيطره القوات المسلحه ويظل هذا الوضع
لسنوات طويله دون ان نصل الى انتخابات هذا
هو الوضع الذي
مهدد امني خطير للبلاد ولذلك القوات
المسلحه تنبهت لذلك ايضا ما شاهدناه
وتابعناه في ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وجدناها ايضا صممت بدقه وعنايه كبيره جدا
من الذين يدعوا الى تفكيك القوات المسلحه
بهدف ان تكون هذه الورشه هي التي من خلال
يتم تفكيك القوات المسلحه برضاها هذا
يعني هدمت اليه هذه الورشه ولذلك المكينه
العسكري رفض توصيات هذه اللجنه واصر على
ضروره ان يكون هنالك جيش وطني واحد قبل ان
نمضي بالعمليه السياسيه تمام وهذا هو
الموقف الذي اذا الاتهام الان لقوات الدعم
السريع ان هذا التحرك خلفه محاوله لافتعال
ازمه من اجل فرض وجهه نظر قائد قوات الدعم
السريع فيما يتعلق بدمج قوات الدعم السريع
بالقوات المسلحه
يعني ليس هناك ليس هناك يعني محاوله لفرض
رؤيه الرؤيه التي يتبناها قائد الدعم رؤيه
متفق عليها وموقعه عليها يعني في خمسه
ديسمبر ووقع عليها قائد الجيش نفسه هناك
محاوله للتملص والتراجع من هذه الله هذا
الاتفاق وبالتالي كذلك ليس هناك مهدد امني
المهدد هو تهديد لمصالح من يتراجعون او من
يريدون التراجع عن العمليه السياسيه وليس
مهدد امنيه تواجهه البلاد باعتبار ان
الصراع الان ليس بين يعني يعني
حافظ في ظل كل المواقف الدوليه التي تحذر
من التدهور في ظل المواقف الداخليه ايضا
والخوف في الشارع السوداني من ان تتحول
الامور الى صدام عسكري
اقصد ان القضيه المتصارعه حولها هي ليست
قضيه يعني الشعب السوداني الان هي قضيه
يعني الطموح وقضيه تمسك القياده الجيش
بالسلطه وليس اكثر من ذلك نحن نفهم ان
المهدد الامني هو المتعلق بقضيه تهم البلد
متعلق مثلا بالتحول الديمقراطي عندما يتم
تقويضه من قبل المؤسسه عسكري هذا هو يعني
التهديد الامني الكبير الذي يتهدد مصالح
البلاد هناك ايضا ادعاء اخر الجيش ظل
متعايز طوال تاريخه مع قواته كان هناك
قوات كان هناك قوات تسمى قوات الدفاع
الشعبي والجيش كان ليس لديه اي اشكال في
وجود قوات مسانده وقوات رديفه خارج سيطرته
كذلك كانت هناك يعني على مر التاريخ قوات
مختلفه ولم يتحدث عن ضروره ان تكون هناك
جيش واحد جاء هذا الحديث الان في سياق
الصراع السياسي في سياق الانقسامات
الموجوده في ساحه ويمكن فهم ذلك من خلال
يعني الخلاف فقط في نقطه السيطره وهناك
ايضا يعني النص في الوثيقه الدستوريه ونص
في اتفاق السلام يقول بوجود قوه الدعم
السريع حتى نهايه الفتره الانتقاليه
احدى القوات التي
قوات حفظ السلام الفريق فتح الرحمن الان
هناك تدخل من جانب القوى المدنيه لمحاوله
حل هذه الازمه بعيدا عن الاطر العسكريه ما
المطروح وما الحلول الممكنه من وجهه نظرك
انا اعتقد انه الحلول الممكنه سهله جدا
القوه السياسيه المدنيه فيما بينها تتوافق
كما قال رئيس حزب الامه الدكتور اللواء
فضل الله بورما لابد ان يكون هنالك تداعي
لكل القوه الوطنيه في ان تتوافق فيما
بينها اذا ما تم هذا التوافق انا اعتقد
انه السبب التباين في المواقف ما بين
القوات المسلحه وغير الدعم السريع سينتفي
وسننزح فتيل الازمه لكن للاسف بعض الاخوه
يزرعوا الى ان يمضوا منفردين هكذا ويسعوا
الى ان يكون الدعم السريع ظهيرا لهم
والضيفك الكريم يتحدث عن انه هنالك كثير
من التجارب وان هنالك كثير من القوات كانت
خارج سيطره القوات المسلحه واقول له هذا
كلام عاري تماما من الصحه كل القوات التي
قامت في السودان اذا كانت شرطه شعبيه او
الدفاع الشعبي او اي مسمى من المسميات
كلها كانت تحت سيطره رواه المسلحه حتى
القوات المشتركه السودانيه مع التي شكلت
عندما تمت توقيع اتفاق السلام مع الدكتور
حتى تلك القوات كانت تحت سيطره رواد
المسلحه لم يكن في تاريخ السودان منذ
الاستغلال هنالك قوه خارج سيطره القوات
المسلحه الا ما شاهدناه في خلال الاسابيع
القليله هذه من خروج القوات الدعم السريع
من سيطره القوات المسلحه بمسانده المكونه
المدني لاعداد هذه الازمه ويسمى بعد ذلك
يجب يتحدثون
القائد شكرا السودانيه السابق وشكرا لحافظ
كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
شهدت باريس ومدن فرنسيه اخرى مواجهات بين
الشرطه ومتظاهرين ضد قانون التقاعد في
سياقه حركه الاحتجاج المستمره منذ ثلاثه
اشهر وقالت الشرطه في باريس ان اثني عشر
شرطيا وثلاثه متظاهرين وصحفيا اصيبوا في
المواجهات ويتوقع ان يحسم المجلس الدستوري
غدا الجمعه في دستوريه هذا القانون الذي
يرفع سن تقاعد الى 64 عاما